gerberas pensée savage échinacée fusée
n'ya donc on va aller dans ce coin là au
coin de deux rues du quartier ahuntsic
en plein montréal une centaine de
variétés de légumes de fruits de finnair
derrière le projet est au milieu de son
lopin de terre
un agriculteur urbain on a fait
d'exploiter soit avec des petits fruits
ou de l'horticulture l'oeil à
l'occupation de l'espace stationnement
donc on s'est réapproprié l'espace même
une partie de la rue on verra plus les
faits il a quitté les bureaux
d'architectes pour se consacrer à la
terre et verdir la ville aujourd'hui
dans sa petite ferme
ils forment il vend et il donne surtout
à ceux qui en ont besoin
devenu le dépannage et légumes mais au
delà des initiatives citoyennes
l'agriculture urbaine est en train de
prendre un essor commercial
lufa avec ses serres sur les toits on
est la vitrine la plus éclatante
et derrière cette vitrine il y a de plus
en plus d'initiatives que le laboratoire
sur l'agriculture urbaine recense depuis
deux ans on a une diversification aussi
des filières sa devront n'est pas
seulement dans la production fruits et
légumes qui on voit que le mouvement est
en train de se répandre partout au
québec
le tout dernier portrait publié début
juillet re 172 entreprises au québec la
majorité dans le grand montréal
c'est une augmentation d'environ 40 % en
un an
un engouement qui pourrait bien être
amplifiée par la pandémie
mais comme l'agriculture traditionnelle
c'est un secteur exigeant
ça reste une opération commerciale
difficile si elle n'est pas soutenue par
le gouvernement
au québec on ne produirait plus de
nourriture
si ce n'était que pour une question
commerciale on achète très top du
mexique plus de la californie les
entreprises en agriculture urbaine
aurait quand même générer environ 17
millions de dollars en 2019 et créer
plus de 600 emplois directs et indirects
et le premier argument de vente c'est le
local
dans ce camion des pleurotes qui ont
poussé dans un autre pot de chéraga ça
va se passer parce que c'est un
champignon qui s'étaient tenus par great
qui est très fragile donc se porte pas
bien les transports sur de longues
distances et respect à baulon temps donc
est vraiment une plus value de le
cultiver proche de là où il va être
mangé
et l'autre avantage de ce champignon
c'est ce qu'ils utilisent pour grandir
avant de sortir par les trous de ses
sauts à raison de 300 kg par semaine
la voici la diète du pleurotes
d'hochelaga les résidus d'une micro
brasserie voisine supprime complètement
un des chefs maman puis en transformant
produits utiles soient de la nourriture
est le substrat épuisé à la fin qu'il ya
d'autres applications si vous servir à
nourrir les insectes des tricycles par
exemple et nous on veut récupérer leur
mycélium donc on va donner encore
troisième vie à ces risques organique là
pour nourrir notre héros oublié ce que
l'on appelle communément les vers de
farine c'est le fond de commerce de
tricycles qu'en quatre ans avec une
première ferme d'élevage essaie de faire
c'est de 2000 pieds carrés
on va le risque 80 tonnes de matières
organiques pour nourrir ce qui va nous
donner environ 7 tonnes d ténébrions à
la fin de l'année mais ce ne sont pas
tant les insectes que les larmes qui
sont intéressantes
je vous invite à essayer d'ailleurs
c'est avec courage ceci sans nature
c'est son barbecue
il ya une barrière psychologique inao
psychologique mais le goût s'apprivoiser
ça quand même beaucoup de
pat comparativement aux grillons en fait
c'est plus homogènes par contre quelle
brillante encore là car à face elle
n'est pas aussi qui réécrit ça peut se
prendre en vue d'un et l'économie
circulaire ne s'arrête pas là car les
déjections d'insectes sont empaquetés et
vendu comme fertilisants et s'ajuste à
ma faim est un qui ce matin a reçu un
petit peu de fumier ténébrions pour
amender les sols
si réal migneault profit d'une tolérance
de l'arrondissement on ne peut pas
encore parler d'un réflexe agriculture
urbaine fonctionnaires qui sont pris
dans la vision des années 80 qui est une
vision qui était à propos mais peut-être
aujourd'hui révolue de dire
l'agriculture
ça se fait en région et la ville
d'enfants on est juste un gros bassin de
consommateurs qui attaquent la région
nous reste à montréal pour l'instant il
n'y a qu'une seule mairie sur 20 qui a
adopté un plan d'action avec un objectif
de 30 hectares d'agriculture urbaine
d'ici 2030
oui on est les premiers à montréal on
maintient la rivière des prairies pointe
aux trembles ya plusieurs secteurs sont
des réelles déserts alimentaires donc
pour lequel vous trouverez pas
malheureusement de marché d'alimentation
avec des produits frais vous êtes obligé
de prendre votre voiture et même de
relier plusieurs kilomètres pour pouvoir
vous procurer de ses produits frais donc
des jeunes je voudrais de réponse même à
la base de sécurité alimentaire qui en
premier lieu la mairesse voudrait que
chaque nouveau projet immobilier qui
n'est pas résidentiel inclut une section
agricole mais pour l'instant il n'y a
aucune obligation réglementaire
il ya aussi cette image de l'est de
montréal même de rivière des prairies
pointe aux trembles qu'ils soient ceux
ci au gris au secteur industriel et
l'agriculture urbaine c'est aussi ça
décontaminer un sol par les plantes
comme ce terrain ici à pointe aux
trembles qui était utilisée avant par
l'industrie pétrolière
il y a dans cet arrondissement 90
hectares de friches industrielles qui
attendent d'être valorisés dans une scic
les terrains vacants sont plus rares et
l'un d'eux va bientôt être transformé
qu'on a enfin conclu l'entente est finie
le bail pour occuper cette parcelle de 6
métiers corée pofalla micro ferme de
quartier la ferme de rue à anne sec 22
espaces de culture qui cherchent
aujourd'hui des partenaires pour pouvoir
sortir de terre